merci pour cette brève présentation je
me présenterai à m'entourent cfa tout
d'abord bonjour mme alliot marie
je suis ravi d'être parmi vous merci de
m'avoir invité pour cette aventure je
tiens encore à remercier principalement
la seine qui a fait la connexion liesse
qui est à l'origine et la création et la
réalisation de cet événement
je vais commencer par quelque chose d'un
peu particulier on m'a demandé de parler
d'humanité
c'est quelque chose d'énorme que je peux
pas moins tout petit être humain que je
suis je souhaiterais partager avec vous
plein d'expérience et de vécu parler
d'humanité sans vous parler du main
alors je voudrais vous prendre dans un
monde surprenant
je vous prends dans un monde hu au je
voudrais vous inviter à un monde
on m'a demandé de parler du futur mais
ma le futur je le connais pas alors et
des histoires des contes qui me reste un
peu en tête et il était une fois il
était une fois la vie la vie autour de
quoi je vais vous demander à tous ici
présents à l'humain qui est en vous de
fermer les yeux
quelques secondes et de s'imaginer de se
laisser emporter dans ce monde
once par la taille des fuites et une
princesse qu'au kenya mais kane fait pas
dix semaines
vauzelle et classe les oléo l air qu al
arabiya à 8
chacun d'entre nous est parti dans son
monde
chacun a son contexte culturel social
économique scientifique physique quelle
que soit de l'ordre de l'énergie
de ce que nous transpose en hausse que
nous ce que nous transporte à les
valeurs que nous véhiculons en est tous
rester humain dans un monde francophone
anglophone chinois arabe ce que vous
voulez dans un monde social quand j'ai
fermé les yeux moi à mon tour j'ai pensé
à une chose j'ai pensé à l'amour on est
tous nés d'amour tous humains que nous
sommes
pour l'amour d'une pomme nous avons
quitté le paradis pour en être dans un
autre peut-être nous sommes tous
il paraît mortels on va mourir un jour
mais moi je pense qu'on est éternelle
jusqu'à la mort alors moi je construis
ma vie je ne sais pas quand sera le
point final alors je me concentrer sur
ma vie la vôtre et ce que nous voulons
en faire alors je vous invite à un
fabuleux coup de foudre avec l'humanité
un fabuleux coup de foudre avec l'humain
un fabuleux coup de foudre avec ma voix
avec xo avec eux ce que vous voulez vous
choisissez vous choisirez votre voix
aussi un coup de foudre à notting hill
un coup de foudre à manhattan n'a droit
juste la princesse ici le coup de foudre
que vous voulez inscrire ou écrire pour
l'humanité pour votre futur lorsque j'ai
commencé à enseigner les statistiques
fait vraiment une matière barbante pour
les littéraires pour les scientifiques
un peu plus complexe à comprendre
j'ai essayé d'humaniser ce que c'était
les statistiques est alors à chaque fois
où je voyais un chiffre je l'imaginé en
un homme avec un grand h
un humain il peut être mon meilleur ami
et peut avoir une allure ses métriques
extraordinaire il peut avoir une logique
binaire de 0,1 ou encore s'inscrire dans
un monde réel de moi l'infini à +
l'infini notre horizon temporel quel que
soit ce que nous souhaitant traverser
est inscrit dans une trilogie est le
passé et le présent et le futur
le passé c'est quelque chose qui nous
construit qui fonde qui fait de nous ce
que nous sommes aujourd'hui grave
l'asile à louis à
pretty woman peut être ça nous construit
tous les livres qu'on a lu les musiques
qu'on a entendu et puis le présent c'est
vraiment l'instant précis ce que je vois
ce que je vis que vous me comblez avec
tous vos yeux l'un le futur c'est un peu
l'inconnu je le connais pas je vais
peut-être rencontrer l'âme soeur un jour
je vais vivre à un coup de foudre ou
peut-être plusieurs en statistiques
la notion d'aléatoire nous inscrire dans
une probabilité dans une chance dans le
hasard mais aussi dans un monde réel
quelle que soit l'expérience aléatoire
le voyage que nous comptons faire dans
le futur ou dans le présent ce voyage là
qui nous anime par amour ou par passion
le plus important c'est le vin que nous
sommes qu'est ce que nous voulons faire
et qu'ils empruntent ou souhaitant
laisser que ce soit pour nous pour les
générations futures
dans cette notion de partage dans cette
notion de valeurs humaines universelles
que nous souhaitons transmettre et qui
nous anime
donc du coup de foudre je souhaiterais
traversé le temps avec vous choisissez
la navette qui vous semble le mans alors
hop le temps qu'on soit dans un cadran
solaire
le temps reste le même nous avons des 24
heures c'est les activités où le temps
que nous allouerons à ces activités qui
sera différent à chaque fois que nous
soyons dans une première montre portatif
ou encore dans un automatisme d'horloge
quel que soit le temps le voyage nous
allons traverser l'espace alors à dos de
chameau à dos d'éléphant mahana mal ou
encore à chevaux des pur sang arabe
le voyage que nous inscrivant sera pour
nous juste un outil pour arriver un
message que nous souhaitons véhiculer
alors moi j'aimerais bien j'aime
beaucoup la couleur rouge ont choisi la
voiture que j'aime après je pourrais
aller beaucoup plus rapidement je peux
choisir l'avion ou encore la fusée
sortir de la gravité terrestre
sortir des concepts sortir d'un contexte
la fusée pour arriver jusqu'à la lune
explorer d'autres planètes et quel
message depuis la nuit des temps on a
commencé à la bouteille à la mer au pij
en messager ou encore les télégraphes
les télégrammes ou temps de guerre ou
encore pour la paix pour l'amour on a eu
les sms les mails et téléphone
hop ça va beaucoup plus rapidement la
technologie est beaucoup plus rapide
qu'avant et tout le monde s'est inscrit
dans l'application qu'il veut premier
message reçu l'email l'émotion que
charge chaque message quel message vous
souhaitez transmettre à ces générations
futures alors moi je vous invite
je vous invite surtout des mais ce qu'il
faut aimer et d'oublier ce qu'il fait
oublier de ne pas vous laisser prendre
dans une indifférence ou un enlisement
de ne pas croire surtout que nous serons
des robotique
on sera surtout des humains que la
technologie facilite la vie oui qu'il y
à du gaspillage certes mais que l'humain
surtout surtout il a une force
d'adaptation
il a une force de transmission il a une
force de pouvoir qui est véhiculée par
l'amour l'amour des autres l'amour du
temps l'amour de soi la mode prochain
l'amour des enfants l'amour des parents
nous avons tous reçu un amour
inconditionnel d'une mère dans pères
frères et soeurs la famille qui
s'agrandit l'humanité entière
we are the world mais nous n'avons
jamais pensé réfléchir en jouant à
pouvoir recycler des déchets double à la
fête larqué mais aujourd'hui nous savons
que nous pouvons transformer dans un
pouvoir de créer une énergie une énergie
qui peut être efficace qui peut être
efficiente une énergie
qui sera utilisé à bon escient je vous
invite souvent de faire la même chose
quel que soit le message que je veux
faire passer quelles que soient les
choses qui m'anime ce que j'ai appris le
plus important pour les agrandir et les
grandir encore plus fort aujourd'hui je
suis serein là le réseau social j'ai
plein d'amis c'est de pouvoir les
partager
yoann est l'étiquette du lavit et chute
vous aimez vous prenez vous partager
alors laisser votre empreinte
ne soyez pas passager dans ce voyage
soyez voyageurs explorateurs soyez vous
même et vous trouverez la voix vous
trouverez votre destin vous créerez une
destinée vous pouvez être un steve jobs
si vous êtes dans la technologie vous
pouvez avoir un prix nobel de la
physique travail les unir avec toute sa
logique vous pouvez être dans un langage
purement binaire en 01 ou encore dans un
esprit de nelson mandela ou par non dans
un esprit de paix raciale et d'avoir
marqué l'humanité
le premier homme qui est parti sur la
lune qui a su transgresser un cadre
connu de tous tout cette attraction
terrestre qui nous tient ou encore marie
curie dans la vie rien n'est à craindre
tout est à comprendre
nous sommes dans une perpétuelle
transformation évolution révolution ou
peut-être même une résolution
cette résolution vous appartient alors
quand on m'a demandé de parler
d'humanité et de parler de l'amour qui
nous véhicules tous ici j'évolue avec
vous partager quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre d'une expérience personnelle de
ce que j'ai vu ce que j'ai vécu ce que
j'ai partagé avec certaines personnes il
faut parfois oser oser sortir du 4 oz et
aimer passionnément à la folie d'un
amour inconditionnel qui vous transporte
j'ai commencé mes études pour remercier
owns qui m'a présenté j'ai insisté de
quelle manière elle va me présenter
10 madame vous êtes enseignante
statistiques économie etc
mon parcours est vraiment atypique c'est
vrai et j'ai commencé tout d'abord mes
études à l'âge de 4 ans et c'est grâce à
l'amour inconditionnel infinie je porte
à ma soeur dont je ne voulais pas être
séparés et l'amour inconditionnel de ma
mère qui a pu convaincre le preuves pour
que je puisse faire mes cours à 4 ans
j'ai suivi mon premier cours en mai en
mettant dans la tête mes parents aussi
c'était que de l'ordre d'une crèche et
il fallait rester là ne pas faire de
bruit
suivant le cours mais c'était juste pour
ne pas faire la fameuse grève de la faim
que j'avais entrepris et ne pas être
dissociée de ma soeur cet amour là
cette conviction cette force d'avoir
transmis un message que je voulais je
voulais apprendre je voulais proche de
ma soeur et je voulais aussi être
gratifiés reconnu par mes parents comme
ma soeur aînée qui était à l'école
ensuite la ventura continuer je
m'identifie est un peu au père je parle
encore couper le cordon ombilical et mon
papa c'est un tout pour moi dumas
expliquer beaucoup de choses dans la vie
de relativiser de prendre la vie telle
qu'elle est d'en prendre le meilleur et
d'être positive mais il est dans une
exposition de partage de générosité é
commencé à écrire les voeux de fin
d'année je ne disais pas pas mais moi
aussi je droit d'écrire des voeux et me
dit oui bah tu écris à qui tu veux mais
je n'ai pas d'amis mais a mis en place
je les vois je lentilles bonne année il
me dit ben tu crées qui tua je dis bah
je vais écrire au président de la
république tient à l'époque je n'avais
que 12 ans je prends est bon à lomé papa
je connais pas l'adresse t'inquiète pas
tu finiras par la trouver
j'ai trouvé l'adresse c'est simple
présidence de la république et je
commençais par les présidents que je
connais françois mitterrand à l'époque
les 10 enfin plein de figure et cette
correspondance là un beau jour une
attaque tak tak un petit message le
facteur qui passe je reçus une lettre le
seul président de la république qui a
osé répondre c'était même pas les
tunisiens ni marocain ne veut rien
italien c'était le français c'était
françois mitterrand ce message là c'est
quelque chose qui m'a frappé
moi tunisienne africaine d'un autre
continent
le message que j'ai véhicule est un
monsieur des plus âgés que mon père de
l'âge de mon grand père qui a pu
répondre et ce message là j'en ai vu une
grande symbolique le symbolique
d'humanité un enfant alors un seul homme
peut faire pleurer le monde mais un
enfant peut le faire changer
soyez toujours les enfants que vous
voulez faire changer quelque chose et ce
message la suite à ça j'ai écrit quelque
chose un message de paix pareil je vois
une affiche c'était un concours
littéraire pour les francophones âgés de
15 ans j'en avais pas 15 ans je suis
parti chez mes parents bien sûr papa je
pas 15 ans qu'est ce que je fais me
disait tu écris tu auras la réponse
parfois on n'a pas le courage de faire
c'est vrai on a peur parfois on veut
juste se soumettre à un cadre à une loin
à des conditions maintenant j'ai
participé j'ai eu le prix du très jeune
écrivain francophone vous le faites pas
vous ne saurez jamais où aller il faut
parfois prendre le pas vers un autre
chemin on aura d'autres choses est bon
autre chose encore comme j'ai le temps
je vais quand même vous offrir à notre
cadeau parce que j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer nelson mandela dans le cadre
d'une association internationale où j'ai
été choisi par les nations unies
pourraient présenter des étudiants et on
se préparait une conférence de presse
chacun ce qu'ils aient posé comme
question
et malheureusement peut-être
heureusement pour moi
nous n'avons pas eu la parole a droit à
la parole
bon elle s'est demandée la quittent le
podium il commence à partir un essai ims
présidente
ils s'arrêtent ils parlent et les
rapports a été changé je lui ai offert
le livre du rapport de l'association et
nous avons parlé donc parfois prenez le
temps de bousculer les choses de l'est
chamboulé de vivre un amour commun un
tsunami je dirais comme un coup de
foudre que vous ne connaissez pas vous
êtes au coeur de l'univers et vous êtes
né d'amour donc si je voulais me
présenter je dirai tout simplement que
je m'appelle olfa à me poser sur think
in je suis une positif plus que ça
deuxièmement avec deux mots je dirais
plutôt passionné et amoureux de la vie
et en quelques mots je dirais que je
suis une personne née d'amour qui
connaît les miracle de l'amour et qui
souhaiteraient partager l'amour dans
cette ère est cet univers je vous
remercie